[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débats le 30 mars pro et
anti chasse à courre ont célébré la fin
de la saison à rambouillet elle avait
une ride est une pratique héritée de
françois 1er jugées archaïques et cruel
pour certains traditionnels pour
d'autres pourquoi cette pratique suscite
autant de débats passionnés entre
chasseurs et défenseurs de la cause
animale c'est le débat du jour autour de
cette table trois invités stéphane
guillou bonsoir bonsoir ans que vous
êtes venu heures et vous faites partie à
de l'équipage bonnel rambouillet sur
pouzauges en face de vous michel
camboulit bonsoir bonsoir
elle vous est le cofondateur du
collectif abolissons à la vénerie
aujourd'hui à rambouillet michel béal
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directeur de
l'agencé au nf ile de france ouest et je
précise que vous serez ne train dans ce
débat vous êtes ici en tant qu'expert on
va dire experts de leforest notamment de
rambouillet merci en tout cas tous les
3es d'avoir répondu présent
alors je le disais donc samedi dernier
une manifestation une double
manifestation même ces tenues à
rambouillet pour et contre la chasse à
courre ont défilé sans se rencontrer
voyons tout de suite quels sont les
arguments défendus par les deux parties
je trouve que c'est vraiment débile on
n'a pas besoin de hiré anniballi pas des
yeux
il faut qu'ils arrêtent ce serait
dommage de faire d'abolir cette chasse
qui n'est pas forcément cruel comme on
peut le penser parce que assure une
chasse ce normal
sur dix animaux de lever on va dire
qu'il ya deux ou trois animaux qui sont
juste prélevé quoi la chasse les
ententes elle me dégoûte pas ce qu'il ya
de moins en moins d'animaux en forêt
parce que le non-respect de la vie parce
que la cruauté de la chasse à courre et
des traditions qui devrait plus exister
comme la corrida
ça fait partie de l'ensemble de la rue
l'invité ce sont les traductions
françaises
alors bien sûr on va revenir sains tout
au long de l'émission sur les différents
arguments que l'on vient d'entendre
stéphane guillou laverny en france ces
dix mille pratiquant il me semble howie
la vénerie seo au moins 10000 pratiquant
sans compter tous ceux qui suivent avec
grand plaisir et en grand nombre faut
savoir qu'en france il ya 400 équipages
essentiellement d'ailleurs qui chasse du
petit gibier lapins lièvres renards
répartis sur à peu près 70 départements
donc sur un ressort territorial qui est
très important c'est une activité qui
non seulement est cynégétique mais c'est
aussi des élevages de chiens
c'est aussi pour ceux qui chassent
sages-femmes des écuries des centaines
de chevaux
enfin bref c'est une activité économique
aussi à part entière alors michel
combeau liste quelles sont les actions
menées tout au long de l'année par parra
va je vous parlais d'avoir oublié
puisque je suis un des cofondateurs et
je donc à ce titre je vais sûrement noté
directement mais bon c'est sensiblement
la même chose dans tout la vague de
france notre objectif notre seul
objectif c'est de documenter la chasse
et documenter la chasse à courre ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire filmé et
photographié et pourquoi documentant de
la chasse à courre doula documentant
pour la faire connaître au grand public
il se trouve assez curieusement même à
rambouillet a maintenant les villages
qui sont dans le massif forestier des
tas de gens ne savent pas qu'il y à des
chasses à courre dans leur forêt donc
notre objectif c'est de la duke
documenté pour montrer aux citoyens
qu'elles existent pour montrer ce
qu'elle est au delà des apparences de la
musique des beaux costumes
pour faire voir réellement ce qui se
passe dans la forêt afin à terme
d'obtenir de la représentation nationale
l'abolition c'est notre objectif quelle
est la réglementation justement
concernant à la chasse à courre homme
jeune et ça se déroule dans la dans la
forêt donc de rambouillet quelle est la
réglementation
peut-être juste avant de commencer les
quatre petites interviews et est
intéressante parce que déjà on voit une
méconnaissance une des personnes qui a
interviewé une dame dit il ya de moins
en moins d'animaux de grands animaux
forêt c'est faux faux
j'allais dire est archifaux passez moi
l'expression que ce soit sur le sanglier
le chevreuil le cerf il est en
augmentation et on a des populations
très abondante dans des forêts comme
rambouillet quand d'efforts et d'autre
des parts d'autres départements de notre
forêt domaniale des yvelines jacques c
c'est important de le rappeler
et c'est vrai que c'est important de
communiquer deux sur dix ans aujourd'hui
pourquoi on chasse parce qu'il n'y a pas
dans notre région d'île-de-france de
prédateurs à ces grands animaux on n'a
pas de lynx on à pas de loup on n'a pas
d'ours sur le territoire d'île de france
et donc si on veut qu' il y ait un
équilibre et c'est toujours le métier du
forestier que d'arriver à ce grand
équilibre un équilibre entre le nombre
d'animaux présents dans une forêt et le
potentiel d'accueil la pop
les nourritures qui peuvent évidemment
les équilibres par rapport à des dégâts
que peuvent causer aussi trop d'animaux
il est nécessaire de les réguler sans
parler du risque d'accident est ce que
trop d'animaux notamment des sangliers
font que ça peut provoquer des accidents
sur la route
donc ça c'est déjà important de le
rappeler que voilà on a besoin des
chasseurs les chasseurs sont aussi là
pour arriver à ce grand équilibre entre
ce que peut cuire une forêt et le nombre
d'animaux juste un mot avec monsieur
qu'on voulait sur cet argument de
régulation c'est en armement je sais
enfin vous réfutez écoutez c'est pas
spécialiste du genre de choses dont la
régulation la régulation et la rega
source sûre bon on régule on régule pas
rompu
plon un chat un chat on tue des animaux
bon monsieur nous dit que c'est
nécessaire effectivement la forêt
tellement domestiques et les les animaux
prédateurs ont été éliminés le renard
est de chasser reste flinguer à longueur
d'année tous les prédateurs sont
disparus alors effectivement les animaux
vont sans doute se reproduise avec une
facilité quoi que tu avais si on prend
l'exemple du canton de genève ça fait
sur 280 kilomètres carrés il n'y a plus
du tout de chasse du tout dans le canton
de genlis ça se passe correctement à
quelques sangliers près à quelques
sangliers près ça se passe très bien sur
280 kilomètres carrés la régulation est
enfin je propose soit j'avais pas plus
malade c'est la spécialité j'y connais
pas grand chose
michel je reviens juste vers vous
justement par rapport à la
réglementation comment on commence à se
battre aujourd'hui en france voilà le nf
travaille avec eux les documents et avec
la réglementation en place et donc la
chasse à courre est autorisée donc à
partir de là comme le disait monsieur
dans un grand nombre de forêt c'est une
pratique qui est possible qu'ils aient
autorisé le nf ne juge pas du bien ou du
moins bien de telle ou telle pratique
c'est une pratique est autorisée on la
met en oeuvre
traditionnellement il y avait depuis
toujours des chasses à courre sur le
massif de rambouillet on utilise encore
cette possibilité c'est tous les samedis
on le rappelle enfin c'est ça vient de
se terminer mais c'était donc tous les
samedis depuis depuis septembre dans le
respect des arrêtés préfectoraux qui
organise et donne chaque année la
période d'ouverture pour la chasse d'une
manière générale la période d'ouverture
pour la chasse à courre qui est pas tout
à fait la même donc évidemment tout ça
se fait dans le respect depuis le code
de l'environnement et autres jusqu'au
niveau préfectoral avec les dates
d'ouverture et de fermeture vers du
nombre d'années
vous n'êtes pas mieux comment ça se
déroule une chasse à courre alors tout
d'abord si vous voulez je revins je
relève quand même que vous parliez de
méconnaissance de la chasse à courre
quand j'entends monsieur camboulives je
voit qu'effectivement il ya
méconnaissance non seulement de la
chasse à courre
mais méconnaissance profonde des
biotopes méconnaissance profonde des
populations animales et la seule
connaissance qui peut avoir j'ai
l'impression c'est un peu sa haine
vis-à-vis de la chasse à courre est un
mode de chasse et derrière peut-être des
idéologies variés qui l'animent
car encore une fois la chasse à courre
c'est quelque chose de populaire donc
éliminons déjà tout ce qui est
présupposé de riches qui se livreraient
à des chasses cruel c'est faux nous
avons des tarifs tout à fait attractifs
dignement tatra coûte combien
mais nous ça commence à 500 euros pour
un jeune et nous avons toute une palette
de façon à ce que chacun puisse venir
donc là il n'y a pas de problème
d'argent ensuite sur les sur les animaux
que nous chassons là encore je constate
une méconnaissance absolue de la manière
de faire d'ailleurs cette méconnaissance
d'havas est assez général par exemple il
suffit d'être d'avoir du bon sens
havas nous dit vous nourrissez pas vos
chiens c'est pour ça qu'ils courent
vous imaginez bien le côté aberrant de
cette position comment voulez-vous des
chiens puissent courir derrière un
animal sauvage dans la forêt s'il était
mal nourris la dernière fois que
j'entendais une amie de monsieur
camboulives qui prétendait donner des
explications une plus jeune est alors la
jeune disait ah mais pourquoi les chiens
cris et l'ancien entre guillemets
d'avant-hier disait ah mais c'est parce
qu'ils ont faim et que quand ils mettent
le nez par terre ils ont faim voyez donc
quand j'entends monsieur camboulives on
va documenter la vénerie déjà levé mais
les documenter depuis quatre siècles
on n'a pas besoin de ce combo lives pour
documenter la vénerie ce que fait
monsieur camboulives c'est pas documenté
la vénerie c'est à partir de son absence
de toute connaissance sur le sujet même
pull et à travers des réseaux sociaux
des gens qui honnit connaissent rien et
là effectivement je rejoins monsieur
cambolive c'est pas tous les jours mais
je vous rejoins effectivement les gens
ne connaissent pas la chasse à courre
mais c'est certainement pas en écoutant
monsieur camboulit laisser certaines ne
monte pas à travers la facebook qui est
une abomination
parce qu'on peut balancer n'importe quoi
et ça c'est je dirait monsieur
camboulives est un pape de la
manipulation sur facebook à partir
d'éléments erronés
d'ailleurs je vous dis monsieur
camboulives on s'est beaucoup fréquenté
cet hiver je vous propose la saison
prochaine s'est contenté de se croiser
on s'est croisé écoutez je vous propose
la saison prochaine que vous venez avec
moi car en ce qui me concerne ça fait
très longtemps que je suis dans la forêt
et ça fait pas dix sept mois que je
m'occupe d'havas et je vous ferai
découvrir la vraie chasse à courre je
vous expliquerai pourquoi les chiens se
récrie je vous expliquerai ce qui se
passe avec le cerf les rues ce qu'il
fait et les raisons pour lesquelles nous
n'arrivons pas à les prendre et là peut
être que vous comprendrez mieux et
pareillement je vous expliquerai
beaucoup de choses je vous invite donc
solennellement monsieur cambolive tous
les deux on n'aura pas besoin d'être
rassurés vous vous avez un vélo
électrique
j'ai un vélo et on fera ça tous les deux
et je vous assure que quand vous aurez
fait avec moi une vraie promenade est
une vraie chasse tous les deux vous
comprendrez mieux ni seul camp voulait
une réaction
oui je vois la vénerie si vous voulez
aujourd'hui et c'est un fait est détesté
par 84%
il vient justement vous parlez très
sondage demandant tout à fait à partir
des apparitions de façon telle charte
novembre 2010 est fait dans les règles
de l'art sur un échantillon
représentatif de 1080 et quelques
personnes donc ça n'est pas contestable
d'ailleurs les veneurs ne le contestera
et chaque samedi et chaque samedi
nous sommes pas là bas c'était pas testé
par sondage scientifiquement certain
sens iphone mais parfaitement vous
faites comment du corps à vie
peu importe peu importe qu'il a commandé
c'est la vie c'est là c'est la fbb vous
pouvez vous le dire il ya un problème il
faut faisait son boulot voilà il ya un
client qui commande un sondage ifop fait
son boulot donc ce sondage n'est même
pas contesté par par vos instances
dirigeantes monsieur j'ai aussi un
passage quand même donc alors là dans
les propos de ce trio c'est tout à fait
extraordinaire par partant d'un partant
de ce constat vraiment du duc de dudu de
besoin qu'ont les citoyens devoir faire
abolir cette activité les veneurs font
assaut de mensonges de sophismes d'
amalgame tout un tas de bidouillages
pour essayer de faire valoir ou il vous
démange reprennent leurs loisirs précis
de faire valoir leurs loisirs
voilà alors monsieur me parle de chiens
rebond auquel très bien c'était présent
en forêt pendant vingt-huit samedi au
passage tout à l'heure vous disiez
madame tous les samedis de c'est aussi
tous les mardis ces deux fois par
semaine voire trois fois en fin de
saison j'ai été présent pendant 28 ou 29
samedi et j'ai vu effectivement ce qui
se passait j'ai vu des serres terrorisée
par ce qui leur arrivait
le cerf qui est qui courent courent
c'est par les chiens c'est ici c'est la
mort aux trousses qu'ils ont ces animaux
j'ai vu des cerfs se réfugier dans l'eau
j'ai vu des serres faire des bonds de
d'un mètre cinquante à deux mètres pour
échapper aux siens et circus et sert
finalement mordu déchiré par le sien les
chiens et noyé par les chiens monsieur
les vues mais non monsieur je l' ai vu
je les vues de ses soldats dissidents
c'est ce que vous dites mais non
monsieur n'est pas non je dis que nos
chiens mangent ce assez
ces citoyens vous entend plus les
citoyens ne veulent plus
c'est très clair alors nous sommes là je
veux lire ah je vous dirais les propos
de votre de votre président de fusion de
la société de génériques monsieur pierre
de roualle qui était interviewé par
season hebdo en mars 2010 8 jan je
voulais propos texto de noces au caire
de wight nous nous pensons que la
société d'aujourd'hui père noël qui
parlent que la société d'aujourd'hui
elle n'accepte plus qu'une chasse à
courre qu'un cerf rentrer dans un dans
une maison dans un village
la société elle est animée par la notion
de bien-être animal par le véganisme
donc ce sont des tendances fortes
lourdes il appuyé sur ces mots et
maintenant tout le monde avait son
smartphone peut filmer quelque chose et
si vous voyez un animal qui se fait tuer
la société le refuse elle ne veut plus
fier de voir le président de la société
de vénerie oui lui a simplement avoir au
bout du compte n'est jamais que le
relais de cette société silencieuse qui
a peur quelque part des chasseurs qui a
percuté par des veneurs à quand un petit
débarque dans un village
avec dix chevaux 40 siens sahurs akrid
partout ça fait peur aujourd'hui les
gens super doué c'est faux monsieur
c'est toujours de manipulateur mais vous
ne me démontrer rien du tout et vous
avez vous avez aussi le la faculté de
projeter dans l'opinion publique des
mensonges et malheureusement là
aujourd'hui où ce n'est vous permettait
on est dans une situation
malheureusement comme disait coluche les
gens ils mangent des poissons carrière
des kills ou dans les coins c'est un peu
ça la population de monsieur camboulives
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
projette sur par facebook à des gens des
mensonges absolus et on raconte des
choses qui n'existent pas les tout ce
que raconte de ce combo leaf sur les
perturbations dans les villages mais ça
n'existe que dans sa tête ce que des
pierres de roualle qu'est ce qui dit il
dit il faut plus faire comme ça puisse
faire par le passé il ya très longtemps
à aller jusqu'au bout de l'acte de
chasse lorsque l'animal va sur des
domaines privés etc
mais c'est tout à fait normal la
vénalité quelque chose de moderne qui
s'adapte d'ailleurs il ya un décret qui
vient de sortir qui enfin qui a modifié
1° pour améliorer cette situation
je ne dis pas que la vénerie est
déconnecté du monde bien au contraire la
vénerie d'aujourd'hui est une verrine
moderne qui s'adapte et on doit
effectivement tenir compte c'est ce que
dit pierre de roualle de l'évolution des
situations de moderniser la longue
agonie que vous faites second set
je sais pas comment je m'en viens danser
rien les les citoyens sur 512 camboulit
on n'a pas à moderniser la réalité de la
vie animale sur le terre vous voulez
peut-être changer de monnaie ne va pas
de gauche d'accord aujourd'hui on a des
prédateurs qui sont dans des forêts nous
ne l'avons plus monsieur bell vous
expliquer que toute manière c'est une
nécessité d'un prêt vers les animaux
vous avez l'air totalement opposées mais
il se fait sachez quand même que quand
il ya une explosion du nombre d'animaux
en france y compris les cancers bits et
non seulement non mais aussi en
territoire et je parle sous le contrôle
de le rôle de laura de l'eau nf dans ses
classes à coup est-ce qu'on est ce que
vous plaît un petit peu nous en dire
plus on n'a pas de rôle dans la chasse à
courre non fixe de caen et son épouse se
déroule samedi par exemple est ce qui a
exclu l'organisation et la charge de
l'équipage donc que lorsque tous baisse
bien le 9 mai qui est ce que les clauses
qui nous lie soit respectée aussi bien
sur les délais etc
il nous les vétérans mais voilà donc là
ce côté là il n'y a aucune aucune
difficulté mais je veux pas rentrer dans
don dans ce débat là aujourd'hui mais
plus largement parce que on l'entend
aussi nous en tant que forestier
la société apporte beaucoup de
contradictions
je vais donner un exemple justement qui
s'éloigne un peu de celui de la chasse
c'est à dire que tout le monde va
vouloir apprécié d'avoir dans sa maison
du bois d'avoir embarqué d'avoir une
cheminée on va brûler du bois d'avoir
deux d'avoir des poutres en bois et
serra va par contre avoir aussi envie
d'aller en forêt pour se promener mais
l'acte de couper du bois et de le
transformer il est aujourd'hui
on l'entend décrier alors parce que
parfois les gens à croire qu'ils
préfèrent que ça devienne decaux est
coupée en amazonie et être brûlés dans
sa cheminée non donc je pense qu'il ya
toujours ce noyau là donc on apprécie de
voir des animaux
certains apprécient de le voir dans leur
assiette mais on veut pas voir ce qui se
passe dans le meilleur maillon central
donc je pense que il faut qu'on fasse
tous autant que l'on n'ait encore les
efforts de de pédagogie de communication
parce que je pense que sur tel ou tel
mode de chasse il ya encore des
méconnaissances une méconnaissance sur
la réalité du nombre d'animaux qui a en
forêt souvent moi c'est mon métier des
reçus pour essayer je reçois
quotidiennement des courriers en disant
on voit plus de chevreuil en forêt à
versailles à versailles là à quelques
kilomètres du château de versailles il y
a jamais eu autant de chevreuil dans la
forêt domaniale de versailles
il n'y a jamais eu autant de sangliers
dans la forêt de marly etc
je peux citer d'autres donc on voit bien
que malgré les moyens importants qui se
décuple avec les réseaux sociaux avec la
télévision ou autre il ya on n'a jamais
autant pourtant communiqué mais sa paire
colle pas jusqu aux auditeurs aux
citoyens aux habitants et on a toujours
des croyances comme ça donc aux idées à
niveau il ya toujours eu plus d'animaux
qu'il faut les réguler aujourd'hui le
hénaff utiliser l'arsenal des
possibilités la chasse à tir à la chasse
à tir en battue la chasse à tir à
l'affût la chasse à tir al'approche la
chasse à courre
donc voilà ce sont tous les moyens
aujourd'hui légaux possibles et qu'on
utilise dans lequel on fixe un cadre
avec des journées avec des nombres avec
également des nombres puisque les grands
animaux les grands cervidés cerfs et
chevreuils sont soumis à des plans de
chasse donc c'est l'eau élèves qui
demande à la préfecture l'autorisation
de tirer un certain nombre d'animaux de
par macif
et la préfecture autorise ensuite et
nous on délègue aux équipages de chasse
à courre en délègue aux sociétés de
chasse qui chassent en partie attire
aussi en forêt un nombre d'animaux le
travail de la nfc de contrôle et qu'il
n'y a pas des dépassements que ça se
fait dans les règles
oui alors on va commencer à conclure ce
que malheureusement le temps le temps
file on va commencer à conclure avec
avec vous stephen stéphane guillou est
ce que est ce qu'on peut dire que la
vénerie encore un avenir bien entendu
que la vénerie un avenir et la vénerie
d'ailleurs vient dans l'ensemble des
modes de chasse décrit comme un
complément c'est tout tout ces modes de
chasse sont complémentaires par exemple
nos chiens font des prélèvements
sélectif
pourquoi parce que certains prélèvements
naturel ce2 qui chasse et par conséquent
nous nous enlevons des forêts des
animaux blessés par les accidents de la
route
c'est pas les chasseurs à terre c'est
nous nous enlevons des forêts les
animaux malades
nous enlevons des forêts les animaux les
plus faibles voilà la réalité c'est ça
et par conséquent on est complémentaire
avec l'ensemble des autres modes de
chasse et en plus nous brassons les
animaux dans la forêt on les fait des
cantonné c'est le terme technique
lorsqu'ils sont agglutinés dans certains
endroits et bien la chasse à courre a le
mérite de pouvoir brasser les animaux
dans la forêt et éviter qu'ils ne soient
trop à proximité est trop dense dans
certaines zones
est ce assez pour ce mode de chasse est
tout à fait utile pour l'ensemble de la
forêt mais aussi pour les agriculteurs
parce que quand vous avez des animaux
qui sont dans bodacc au tpiy qui sortent
toutes les nuits pour ravagé les
cultures là c'est pas monsieur béal
qu'ils seraient là pour râler mais ce
sort sans et l'autre ce sont les
agriculteurs
donc il ya vraiment un complément des
modes de chasse et la chasse à courre
est tout à fait adapté et en plus c'est
magnifique
il faut venir mais il faut venir sans
eau sans avoir été discuté avec monsieur
camboulives à vendre parce que sur ça
vous êtes pour rien voilà mais ça va
s'arranger à ce qui va venir faire du
vélo puis le second voulez vous
l'avenir du vélo et vous allez apprendre
la chasse à courre mija camboulives mon
jeu je connais déjà votre réponse savoir
s'il avait un avenir non annulables la
vénerie n'a pas d'avenir
les filles à il ya quelques années les
citoyens foulée sur l'abolition 62 13 %
en 2005 c'était 78%
on en est à 84 % tout simplement parce
que la société de l'acceptent plus vous
parlez de régulation il faut régler quoi
vous avez tué convient de faire cette
année ça sert cette ville 16 sert aux
frais de rambouillet convient de
s'arrêter monsieur réal contrat
complémentaire de l'homicide et six mois
à conclure s'il vous plaît combien
viennent pas assez passé ont très bien
ce curieux
bon je vais conclure ce que vous avez
déjà là j'ai dit deux mots pour eux pour
vous répondre que je dis pas assez
simplement parce que aujourd'hui
oui il ya trop de serre par rapport aux
capacités d'accueil en forêt de
rambouillet une partie est régulé avec
la chasse un cours d'autres avec la
chasse à tir aujourd'hui à la saison
2018 2019 par rapport aux nombres qui
était autorisée par le préfet dans la
forêt de rambouillet ans n'a pas atteint
le maximum on en est loin
donc aujourd'hui ça veut dire que il y a
une population qui est en augmentation
par rapport aux capacités d'accueil
parce qu'évidemment dans l'eau est en
train de bouffer montant de si vous le
permettez je vais conclure frais minutes
pour conclure les prochaines actions
d'avoir dans la question qui est
l'avenir de la chasse à courre la chasse
à courre est condamné c'est pas moi qui
le dit la chasse à courre est aux abois
c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont des
instances de la société john lennon et
pourquoi pourquoi est la preuve la
meilleure preuve de cette situation que
la société de vénerie et bonheur ne
savent plus comment s'y prendre doit
arriver à se sauver ils font appel aux
chasseurs tous les chasseurs mais
maintenant ils en sont à faire appel aux
éleveurs cultivateurs aux bouchers
charcutiers lors de la lors de la
manifestation qui a été organisé à
rambouillet par par les veneurs ils ont
été faire jouer de la trompette sonné la
trompe de chasse devant une boucherie
charcuterie mais parce que vous attaquez
la rue
c'est la rue réclame tout ce temps de
chien sûr que c'est un penseur victoire
cruciale camboulives la saison la saison
est terminée ce qu'il va y avoir
d'autres actions d'avoir rambouillet
avant le début oui nous continuerons à
tous et continuant à agir pour
sensibiliser les citoyens et faire en
sorte que nous soyons encore plus
nombreux pour documenter la chasse à
courre documenté on va être photographié
et filmé ce qui se passe voilà cette
émission est déjà fini merci en tout cas
tous les trois d'avoir répondu présent
d'être venu défendre vos points de vue
merci l'aude on se retrouve mercredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro du 7
fait débat
[Musique]